chris grew the gm of the dolphins was
busy on friday afternoon in addition to
the trade with the 49ers
they end up doing a trade with the
eagles where the dolphins moved from 12
the pick they acquired from san
francisco up to six eagles go down to
12. so the dolphins come out of this
with a net of the sixth overall pick
this year they move down three spots
they pick up
a future
first round pick in the transaction and
a future third round pick in the
transaction this all flows from the back
end of the laramie tunsil trade where
they got two first round picks from the
texans labor day weekend of 2019. the
dolphins have been making a lot of moves
they stockpile picks they stockpile
picks they move and they move and their
team is gradually getting better and
hilarious with the statue outside of
hard rock stadium because that tonsil
trade continues to bear fruit for the
miami dolphins my guess is they'll keep
flipping those picks well into the
future there will be picks with ties
back to laramie tunzel for the rest of
the decade i i mean it's it's
unbelievable i mean first tunzel he
deserves a statue out there maybe billy
o'brien deserves one to go along with
that um
but but i i just you can't say enough
about chris greer and brian flores and
what they've done since they've taken
over in miami you know again
i don't want to say it's you know i'm
not like it's shanahan mcveigh the
dolphins just every year so far just
been like here chip's in the middle of
the table we're making moves we're going
for it i mean that's the first thing i
love about it the second thing i love is
just knowing like knowing how the board
is kind of shaking out for the nfl draft
right hey we got pick number three hey
there's some quarterbacks that people
might like hey
we need a wide receiver and
nobody does in front of us in fact we
don't need to be at number three to get
a wide receiver you know that's what by
by all accounts that's what i would
expect this is all about so now you
trade down you know
get go to number so you're at number
three you trade down with the 49ers to
get to number 12. but now you go wait
we're at number 12
and the two receivers that we want jamar
chase or devonte smith they could be
gone by number 12. let's find somebody
to make sure we can trade back up and
make sure at the very least
in a crazy world
that at least one will be there
and that's where i think it's beautiful
by the miami dolphins they trade back up
to number six and now you're assured of
a jamar chase
or a devonte smith for the most part i
mean it would be very odd for me to
think the falcons would take a receiver
or something like that with julio and
calvin they could trade out they could
trade a good trade out there put them in
themselves in a really good spot more
than likely to get one of those two guys
to help out their young quarterback in
tua
you don't go
to six where you essentially will have
at worst the third non-quarterback off
the board you don't do that unless you
have three non-quarterbacks that you
love
plain and simple sure so they're content
if if it is chase and smith at at four
and five because the falcons and bengals
trade down with teams that spring up to
get a receiver then then they'll take
somebody else at number six but they're
content with that and at the end of the
day
hey they're gonna get equivalent value
at six that they would have gotten at
three and they picked up an extra first
round pick and third round pick in the
process so this was a masterful move on
the chess board by chris greer to find a
path to getting the same or similar guy
that they would have gotten a three at
six
and and another
future first round pick that can be used
or traded or part of a package to move
down or up or whatever and and i love
that move from the dolphins perspective
because they come out of it basically in
the same position they were in but with
more assets in the future yeah that's
right they come and then you know to the
point too where you know i think you're
right you got to think there's at least
three guys there that they got their eye
on to go hey we're happy that if any of
these three come to us at number six
we're in the perfect spot and at the
very worst you know if they got win that
four and five might take a player that
they really like or want or whatever
like you just said too they got a ton of
assets to make more moves here if they
wanted to get up another spot or two
that's not going to be an issue but i do
think ultimately it is about one of
those two receivers as far as
positioning themselves in number six and
i don't know which one it is you know
like i said chase devonte smith it's 1a
1b it's ballers they're ballers um but
uh it's really it was great maneuvering
by them and the dolphins the way their
team is set up i mean it's just you look
at it mike you go damn i mean really
position by position they're in a good
spot now it's just about hey i mean can
we hit with some superstars here in the
draft and you know what else do they do
as far as trade wise to maybe get other
players or other you know marquee moves
here as we go forward
and this can be interpreted as sort of
like what the giants did in signing
kenny gallaudet if you're going to go
all in with your first round top 10
quarterback you need to give him some
help giants did it with a free agent
exactly dolphins doing it with a high
first round draft pick when you look at
what production or lack thereof they got
last year from their receivers look at
that the max 793 from devonta parker who
was targeted 103 times with 63 catches
they need more production than that in
the receiving game to get more out of
tuatanga by loa and and if if you get
devonta smith or jamar chase and and tua
doesn't get it done this year then next
year maybe the dust has settled on the
desean watson situation you trade for
him then i i really do think you know my
first thought chris when they bumped
from 12 back to six well maybe they're
still kind of potentially in play for a
quarterback
but
i i i tend to to think that like you do
this is about getting a skill position
player to help the quarterback they have
i think so i think they said hey we
picked to it number five let's try to
make this work you know we got a good
football team
there's definitely room to grow from tua
that we know of we did see some good to
think that there could be you know more
good coming down the road there's no
doubt and i think realistically when you
evaluate it too to your point to what
you just said you know it's not like he
had weapons galore all around him
i think that's the big thing i mean
devonte parker is really good when
healthy you know preston williams can
help out a lot and he is really good
when healthy but health has not been
like some of their strengths there and
gaseki their tight end is the second
leading receiver like i think everything
we showed on that graphic about their
receptions and receivers and everything
like that that just shows you they have
a desperate need at that position they
need more production there and i don't
think you can go wrong with either one
chase or devonta smith there i think
either one's gonna help out tuatanga
viola a whole lot and uh i i i think it
is about supporting him and trying to
make it work
yeah and they're in a division that is
very competitive and getting more
competitive all the time we know what
the patriots have done this off season
what the bills are and have become the
jets with zach wilson if he ends up
being picked number two yeah and a good
start agency competitive difficult
division you got to do what you can to
keep pace in what could become the afc's
version of the nfc west
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports